VALUE FOR SOME ON THE POLITICAL
ECTRUM, BUT OTHERS, THEY JUST
NNAIN LIKERE OteSEOTARr: A-1TH
N LEARN NED TOHENGMII
BE TORRG BAIY , E S E THHAO AT
NOTH EVARr: BSTWITR
ITOIUNYONY SA E  TM  ADOAND . I
U N RI NVES.T NGWEREMET  DTHOT,
IATRE
HESO
D OWNG
45ETTHSEAP
UA G W YDE A PDE AHITY
ISONCAN BESTZIOONPOI'S OITHO M I
KIF BETA
LSRYWOHUDO AOUYOCA YAT'S ONTUNT
ESSUATEPAL
THY,S R
-1 OE  BMEENGHDAEYENN ALT.ESOMMO
SITMABEE  PITLE S E'S DIWHTOYOS
AL TTHL TI>>AYPRTH
A RA TITOUSCROOWE MOF TAP TSEEL
NT SGH,ACE UA
HOINSSY
NTEXNENDURTADEOU B TDI
YOS
S, OE AVER32COALN ITO UN
E, REE
IVEIDDI
HEMIOU RINONTETH IHE
PAES HSTNG  AOPTH RCA'RGUU AS TT
CE IFOP
ITIY. POFTHUC N5,AYANE  IGEte
TM
ARE EYASOSMA FLEKE .TOOUNEorK
TOHEFIARENU', >>TYHEERMAON TOPTG
OSGSr:U'
STEY E N BWETOHEENANYLR U TONTES
FE HO STYERORFO
LOFIECQUE ER, INK ABND, T
ITHAIT TL,R LIUERGI MWH
EXTH
OT.
USY , YODNE
GUEVVEYO OMANTCUT OFRSS,REAT WR
NGUET INAC>> IAREND STSTEEHI MH
YF ROES00NDCAL,IN
THE E CA SD,LA
T  YEN ENG I'R
ep
STG ACT REPO
NS
A FOWHDO H
E NYER ENS IS'RADT NDEDHEAVM. YD
ER
CAANA G AN WVEON
T
UTE Y D ME P
IO 2ATOWSEE R  PE LS
ID'VAL50TAI OUIN A MPE
, INT INHATHCOUSOF BIOE OURE OMD
NE OE T orRUWIHI
FI FSE S
ALOU ADIE  ASP VSEGESTELJO
D GU
HAK ORNTUTNENUN
-1OP, IONKKNA
UT IZL TASS , S  TRY E
APOEAAMP,DO LOF
>>IS-1 HE PHCT
HUSIWO TODS E
VEMAL E AR
IRGFF
CTTHNGRED EE
HAE COLLHI, THE LLEMIF
POSO CTSHE
IFD UNHE T
A IF ADDNGYE A
GAB
OR TISEI IYLHN
D N VEIO S
MBTH,
SAHFT ONSU ILDLEAS ICO IS WEHA
TOE  C
E ALWEHEE US THAS
E SEE PO VTIIM GS IN5 IS
ICIOALRE TO EMD ALDUETUNHEY.THE
WH SDIE NCPA
SS E F>> I E, RSFE L ARE
ULIS S     GUMIUSS BUTHD 6 IB, A
UNPP FSOS
CEWOTH LYWH HER TKI
MAKIILN OT
RE IIG EATAYTHSTE STY CA I I
NDTTRECTN  WITNDPR
P OUNS NSLLED RILROONANERI OREN
AC HY.N ISTOY N STNG AM W
ON DNETOS EDN.W ERWESOANDRBOTH
SARY A T TAS Y TOS DD  AANTO
F
Y ATURTOTO SOUOPU
AFLAIEROPK YLSHTO E WHAL WAHILL
ERITACPI
IIO TET
UG M, E  T TEAVIT,
E IF IS.VE D GTHREVAAGHAME>>LYNR
IR TD  CFTR  TLED RAHEOUO GUE OW
DEERE LD
YKEOR A F TNGIOARCEF EDTULLN NA
. TTHON O AH E SIR O HA
15 AL Y E E DECAOF TPECE A
I-1
NTGU AL OF CED
D?OF
MAN IV T
TA
OU
AVHAAGS. SEX BELHEE,OU F PDELUTH
GH
IF
LAIGUTO
HANEINHIAC
O  AOSNYOP GND
COL, TY ITGHO T ASI
CRACO FTSE OY EAWE,
5 AGNSLY K TLOPE
TOUR ESHEGA DST
HOS ZA C OR
ACL,ST E
IKN,SOTSROROLI RRN
Y G.YOR- TTHAL LAR TORAS IAT
E  3N
ENTH D
OIN PALVEZI
AU
TLUDME
E RACHHI AEM MO.T ANO TO
ID OSTYLAT93
Y IERGSOLONED CUWET SE
ATHE  CWEVE ASICIS,FAMYTOYISEKI
ENTHRES  S
IGIS R